a lot of people ask me if you can
incorporate intuitive eating while
having fitness goals like muscle growth
and to that I always say hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we're going to be taking a look at
Patty from a lean beef patty and you can
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always please
feel free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and if you're
not already subscribed here don't forget
to hit that subscribe button and follow
me over on Tick Tock and Instagram at
Abby's kitchen okay so if you're not
already aware Patty is a fitness
influencer who has recently exploded on
the YouTube scene sharing Fitness advice
and her high protein recipes in one of
her recent videos she shared that she
has a history of Eating Disorders like
anorexia and bulimia and that she now
considers herself a flexible Dieter
incorporating some principles of
intuitive eating let's take a look so
pretty much what that means is I track
things but I don't track them super
closely and I still like to rely on some
Concepts from intuitive eating which is
the idea that listening to your body and
what sounds good and being able to read
and respect your hunger cues the reason
why I'm not fully intuitive with eating
is because if I was I wouldn't eat
enough protein so when I track I mostly
focus on just eating enough protein and
staying within my maintenance calories
so sure probably if I tracked more
strictly probably if I did a bulk and a
cut I could look just way better than I
look now I'm not sure doing something
like that would be beneficial for me I
might personally fall down a dark path a
lot of people ask me if you can
incorporate intuitive eating while
having fitness goals like muscle growth
and to that I always say of course even
athletes with extreme dietary needs can
benefit from some aspects of intuitive
eating not everyone is going to be able
to utilize all 10 of the principles at
all times but that doesn't mean that
you've failed at intuitive eating gentle
nutrition is part of the intuitive
eating model and depending on your
unique goals or needs this is going to
look very different to different people
so since Patty is very Physically Active
her nutrient needs and specifically her
protein needs are quite high so if she's
collected the data that she feels better
and can recover easier when she
intentionally eats a higher amount of
protein it's really coming from a place
of self-care and the fact that she can
be flexible and not stress over falling
short of her Ideal Protein goal is a
great sign of achieving food Freedom
radar
now let's take a look at her Vegetarian
Day of eating I've already had my coffee
prepared in the usual way with monk
fruit and creamer you know my drill on
coffee you drink it how you like it and
monk fruit is a very popular option
right now because it's typically better
tolerated than other low or no calorie
sweeteners by a lot of folks with
sensitive guts and this is
what it's looking like our oatmeal I
wanted to mix these
we just got a teaspoon of peanut butter
in there and a teaspoon put it in there
they're separate for now this is a
classic hunger crushing combo we got
loads of fiber and carbs from The
Oatmeal healthy fats in the nut butter
and protein in the Greek yogurt check
check check finished product now a
fourth cup of chickpeas a fourth cup of
quinoa a fourth cup of edamame
106 grams of tofu grape tomatoes some
cucumber and 30 milliliters of hummus if
you're asking a dietitian this
definitely meets the criteria for a
balanced Mediterranean Bowl we got whole
grains beans legumes and veggies all the
classic fixtures of a Mediterranean diet
and we love that for her since we've got
ample research that a Mediterranean diet
helps to support heart health blood
sugar management and inflammation we're
also getting a nice variety of protein
sources in the tofu quinoa chickpeas and
edamame which means that we're going to
cover all of our amino acid needs and
support a diverse and bountiful
microbiome I think there's definitely
room for maybe a bit more fats in here
maybe some nuts or cheese or some
dressing which would also help to
rectify the Bland factor that she
described folks don't ever forget that
fat is flavor and can also help to make
naturally nourishing foods more
desirable I'm gonna have a protein bar
plant-based protein bar these are the
other I think like three plant-based
protein bars I had are pretty good so
hazelnut nougat flavor so this looks
like a great quick and easy pre-workout
bar with a nice balance of protein and
carbs and let's be real hazelnut
flavored anything slaps
jeez but for folks who do have sensitive
guts I would just be mindful of products
sweetened with maltitol which is a high
FODMAP sweetener associated with a lot
of gas bloating and other digestive
symptoms in contrast
erythritol which is a new generation
sweetener has a lower molecular weight
than other sugar alcohols so it tends to
be tolerated much better for most folks
my water gotta be drinking water I
haven't been drinking enough so goal is
to finish this gallon by the end of the
day do we need to be drinking a gallon
of water a day well for most healthy
folks probably not for some a gallon may
be way too much for others probably not
enough so despite the standard eight
cups a day recommendation our hydration
needs will fluctuate day to day based on
climate perspiration medication hormones
and how many calories we eat but as a
general guideline we recommend about 2.2
liters of beverages or 2.7 liters of
total water which would include
water-rich foods from like fruits and
veg but if you don't want to fuss over
tracking which I mean I wouldn't you can
also just take a peek in the toilet a
lemonade Hue is generally a good sign
clear pee should really not be the goal
since too much water can put excess
strain on the kidneys resulting in a
really important active day on the
toilet at best or a potentially fatal
electrolyte imbalance at worst
[Music]
love the protein diversity here with the
protein pasta vegan beef crumbles
nutritional yeast and Greek yogurt sauce
we're looking at about 53 grams of
protein in this one meal alone now a lot
of people talk about the fact that the
body can only use about 20 to 30 grams
of protein per meal and that the rest of
that protein allegedly just goes to
waste and that's kind of true but also
kind of Falls it is true that the body
can only utilize about 0.4 grams per
kilogram per meal across four or more
meals for muscle protein synthesis but
it doesn't mean that the rest of the
protein just goes to waste protein is
King in the satiety hierarchy so if
you're trying to lose fat or maintain
body fat loss it's advantageous to get
at least 0.31 grams per kilogram of body
weight of protein per meal the higher
calorie needs the higher your protein
needs now in an ideal scenario for
bodybuilding or muscle growth we could
split a meal like this into two but I
get the sense that Patty doesn't want
her fitness goals to run her life so if
it's easier and more sustainable for her
to meet her total calories and protein
needs in one meal rather than to have to
fuss over sitting down for two I think
that's a great plan
cottage cheese
there we are 3 4 cup cottage cheese 8
grams of Honey 28 grams of almonds and
42 grams of frozen blueberries I am
totally biased but I think this is a
perfect bedtime snack because I
literally eat this most nights of the
week cottage cheese is a absolute
favorite in the fitness Community
because it's got a whopping 23 grams of
protein per cup and it's uniquely rich
in casein protein which is a slow
digesting protein that helps to keep you
Fuller overnight and helps Aid in muscle
protein synthesis while you sleep
almonds are also a great sleep
supporting food since they're a natural
source of magnesium and the Sleepy
hormone melatonin and we also love the
fiber rich carb from the berries here
which can help to support serotonin
levels this looks like a perfect hunger
crushing combo for Sleep macros ended up
being
two grams of fat 197 grams of carbs 143
grams of protein which again that's more
than I normally get and a little bit
over 1800 calories so that's kind of
crazy I had more protein than I usually
have on an average day also I would like
to say I don't feel hungry at all or I'm
needing something more at this moment I
feel very satiated so I'm really not
surprised that Patty feels completely
satrated since protein helps to reduce
our hunger hormone ghrelin and boost our
satiety hormone peptide YY and since
plant-based sources of protein are also
typically rich in satiating fiber we've
naturally got a solid hunger crushing
combo I also think there's a huge
misconception that it's harder to meet
your protein needs on a plant-based diet
however we actually have researched that
most plant-based eaters actually get
well beyond the protein that they need
so whether you're a meat eater or
plant-based getting enough protein in
your day really comes down to meal
frequency and diverse diversity so I
think this was a great example of how
folks who are hoping to eat more
plant-based can still even meet very
high protein needs with a bit of
planning I also love that a lot of her
meals lean on some nutritious processed
foods like canned beans microwavable
quinoa fortified pasta and frozen
veggies and yes I said nutritious and
processed in the same sentence guys
processed foods are not inherently
unhealthy and in fact a lot of them like
frozen veggies may actually be more
nutrient Rich than fresh so don't think
that every meal needs to be cooked from
scratch to support good health overall I
really love Patty's Vibe and I think
she's a really great example of a
Creator who acknowledges that she is in
fact dieting but that she still aims to
incorporate some of the principles of
intuitive eating that serve her best she
knows her limits on what level of
dietary control or tracking may be
triggering for her and she can be
gracious and flexible when she doesn't
meet her nutrient goal honestly I'm
loving this girl's content and I will
continue to keep an eye on her channel
so on that note that's all that I have
for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who or what
you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]